posez des questions sur ces lignes on
sait très simple tu vas venir ici tu as
doit répondre aux questions j'avais
maintenant pas d'agir maintenant si tu
réponds bien on écouta morceaux de ton
nouvel album poison par contre si tu
réponds mal tu as doit répondre à une
question très personnelle d'un
chroniqueur il en parlant ici il ya
détecteur de mensonges on verra si tu
dis la vérité ou pas à la voir voilà
voir away se dise un truc qui nous
auraient ils nous ont envoyé des états
unis on en train de l'amortir salif ils
ont l'envoyer frère et croyez qu'on a
utilisé une fois les gars atd america
sony - vont l'utiliser une fois parce
que ellen degeneres tafer mais en fait
aux états unis et la première émission à
quillan voyez c'est nous et donc ils
sont libres anouma est ce qu'il va le
faire ou pas je ris peut-être après je
leur ai dit c'est gratuit et m'ont dit
oui chez nous on va le faire tous les
jours donc alors petit rappel sur le
fonctionnement du détecteur de mensonge
donc le micro est relié à une machine
même tu verras tu diras juste oui ou non
on va voir si tu mens ou pas et à la fin
tu auras droit de vous poser une
question à moi également je n'irai pas
ok là comme d'habitude
alors une question sur céline dion à
questions faciles dans l'émission the
late show with james corden on a pu voir
ces lignes ont parodié le 11e mariage de
benjamin castaldi
un clip de jay-z et beyoncé une scène du
film titanic où l'élection de donald
trump
tadjau
une scène du film titanic est ce assez
tranquille c'était ça c'était une race
et ans car paul caro qui est regardée
sont montés dans un bateau voilà ils ont
parodié la scène de titanic regard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses chansons préférées tiennent bon s'il
suffisait à 6,8 et ouais si tu faisais
qu'on s'aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on débouche à raison de france en 1988
céline dion elle remporté l'eurovision
avec le titre ne partez pas sans moi
[Musique]
alors pigalle pays quel pays représentés
tels ya isabelle morini bosc qui lève la
main et des tubes à dallas mais la
lâcher alors attention quel pays
représentés tels la france la suisse la
belgique ou la tunisie
la suisse la suisse bonne répond enfin à
laver battant alla des vacances et
lignot quand elle a gagné leur billet tu
fais leurs occasions tant pour la france
ou pas pourquoi pas c'est vrai à ça
pourrait chauffer j'aimerais bien qu'on
gagne ça serait bon gars qui joue plus
on l'eurovision
ouais tu voiture est tiré avec une des
chansons de son album sur la tête de ma
mère si on termine pas dans les cinq
premiers je vous dis pourquoi dans les
5-6 qu'hier alors sur les quais pour
être pas taillé premier parce que quand
tu termines premier tu d'organiser
l'année d'après la wii ça coûte cher 30
bar c'est une tannée deuxième c'est bien
même dans les cinq premiers et fouet
puis au pire des cas on gagne on
demandera de l'argent aux c'est ce grand
fan de ces lignes ont voulu préciser que
le même soir de l'eurovision est allé
dîner elle après impôts balle à monter
dans sa chambre et c'est ce jour là
qu'elle perdra sa virginité
le 30 avril 1981 avec l eurovision elle
a perdu sa virginité
le soir à fêter ça
[Rires]
c'est quoi le rapport il a été lui non
non non non non non j'ai fait une
émission avec rené ya deux ans il ya dix
ans c'est rené qui m'a raconté lila il
l'a même après un an après il a raconté
dans un livre pas erroné il a dû en fait
ça c'est pas passer tout de suite c'est
ouf parce qu'elle est elle le chauffer
quand il l'a raccompagné dans la chance
ça va je l'espère de l'image de céline
dion
[Applaudissements]
céline voulais que ce soit lui là il
raconta eh ben on s'est raconté l'homme
est important c'est bon c'est bon non
mais franchement c'est un scoop c'est un
truc où je suis je savais pas ça le
lendemain c'était férié tous les six
bateaux d'accoster alors regardez
[Musique]
m
c
[Musique]
quelques jours sur mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les gens qui nous regardent se
disent et dire que céline noah prêt à ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ajouter les frères thébaux est là mais
dans quel état n'est comme ça à faire
[Rires]
moi je suis fier que ce soit de celles
dont oui mais oui mais oui et toi tu
nous as trahis alors sunjata balkaniser
c'est leur web a placé les news et ça
c'est une voie royale à ces lignes on
les 10 de son mari pascal chercher tous
les 10 de ceux de son mari au départ il
s'est fait partie d'un groupe les
baronettes commerçants français nous
fatiguer à les chanter
c'est une ville on s'est arrêté de
chanter pendant un concert pour faire
quoi pour laisser le temps une personne
de faire pipi pour annoncer qu'une fiat
panda devait être déplacée pour qu une
choriste puissent manger un sandwich
pour que sa coiffeuse vienne l'arrco
fait refaire son brushing
c'est quoi ces lignes on ne les regarde
pas il se bat pour le brochet au
brushing
alors on va voir on va voir c'était lors
d'un concert regardez regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc quelqu'un peut poser une question
haddad joue avec le détecteur de
mensonges dazhou choisi une personne
nous tous une question pour toi est ce
qu'il ya une chanson que tu n'assumes
pas on assume plus même très ancienne
il ya un son un son de justin bieber toi
quand j'étais petit je crois le sens il
s'appelle never let you go on dirait les
sonneries school music hall tout ça mais
je le kiffe le sont pas on dirait pas
mais qui va nous dire ce qu'il a dit là
il avait frère je me permets tu ça lui
fait un point commun avec maxime gagne
c'est vrai ah oui c'est vrai et ouais
t'as pas eu que des bonnes nouvelles
telus tt tranquille faire ouais t'es pas
bien attention quel stade de quelle star
internationale céline dion était la
cousine éloignée
fabien lecoeuvre le gars qui est là mais
c'est grave possible lady gaga ou
madonna
ah ouais mais céline dion est la cousine
éloignée d'une de ses stars une femme
ses trois stars et un couffin si on dit
vas-y mon fabuleux cadre garou lady gaga
ou madonna
de quelle star internationale céline
dion était la cousine éloignée
gao garou oui et non madonna céline dion
neige sont cousines éloignées
elle n'aura en urgence être en commun
eh ouais ce n'est pas vous savez quoi
madonna et céline dion voilà son
témoignage on va prendre une question de
beinheim allez venez date us que tu as
déjà eu une aventure avec une de tes
fans m'attendent dans repose plus forte
ça parce que j'aime bien et tu réponds
juste par oui ou par non te donnerai pas
de t'inquiéter pas avoir du monde est ce
que tu as déjà eu une aventure avec une
de tes fans est dans la merde
non on va voir oui c'est vrai bravo il
est honnête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tdc croyez pas tu vois tu vois que tu es
honnête en plus chouette s'était vu le
nom était bien et toi non mais moi qui
répondait à une question à poser tout à
l'heure d'aller là tu l'as faudra là
pour l'instant on est dans des on est
sur toi mais je vais me reste une
question une rue située dans le show de
jimmy kimmel
céline dion a fait une surprise à des
anonymes en chantant lors d'une
circoncision d'un anniversaire d'une
demande en fiançailles d'un mariage un
jeu
elle a fait une circoncision un
anniversaire une demande en fiançailles
ou un mariage le pauvre dadou mr tunisie
gourmette les questions mon truc mais là
on régis frères ils sont perdus là j'ai
changé un peu lent d'avoir la cei
[Musique]
alors céline dion elle a fait une
surprise à des anonymes ou chantant lors
de quoi je sais pas franchement je sais
que tu veux qu'on me pose la question de
mon de fiançailles une demande de
fiançailles
alors céline a surpris un couple et
toute une famille lors d'un mariage dans
une chapelle à las vegas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
justin secondes
bordeaux
tu me plais tous mes disques
[Applaudissements]
m
je veux amener
[Musique]
sur le
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi vous allez poser une
question d'âge ou attention y répond par
oui ou par non et le détecteur de
mensonges fera son travail
tatchou vous déjà sortie avec la même
fille que votre frère alors on rappelle
que souffert c'est bouder offert ses
légumes c'est bien sûr non jamais jamais
alors est ce que tu veux dire non mais
on n'a jamais non non non non
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'il ya mon frère vous avez
aimé les films et les branchements du
bayou passé c'est chelou franchement je
je je
jj oui j'y crois pas trop dernière
question qu'est ce qui est vrai à propos
de céline dion elle est la cadette d'une
famille de 14 ans son chien s'appelle
ziggy elle a fait une apparition dans
l'appareil de la petite maison dans la
prairie où elle est propriétaire du
restaurant chinois pour que tu m'aimes
encore il faut augmenter ses 80
famé de 14 ans iep 14 enfants c'est bien
sûr une bonne réponse céline dion c'est
la cadet d'une famille de 14 enfants
avaient fait une reprise du titre à la
claire fontaine toute la famille de
cindy regarder
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je la
tout d'abord me posais une question si
tu veux l'être d'un chroniqueur tu
n'hésites pas tu pourras me pose une
question je répondrai par oui ou par non
et vous tu as vu que le détecteur de
mensonge est tout à fait fiable tulle a
pu le tester pour toi alors où tu as une
question en tête où tu peux demander la
même question en tête ah merde
vas-y sert il
à chaque fois que je viens
tu me diras tu joues tu es trop beau
je t'aime à la folie ouais à chaque fois
que games il vient tu lui dis la même
chose tu arrives à ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est tu préfères gims ou dazhou
partiel il ya quelqu'un pour qui tu es
tu mens en fait ohlala alors déjà je ne
ferai plus oui ou non mais on n'a pas de
moyens on se dit juste z man games jeudi
son hôte des jo mais je peux pas faut
que j'aille monde parle de pardon donc
il faut que ça coûterait l'aptitude à
osaki tu préfères est ce que tu me
manques je te préfère à guînes parce que
tu me préfère moi à games je peux
quitter l'émission j'adore ça c'est la
merde pour centrer toit pendant 2
reviendra cette question de dazhou tu
m'a posé une question il ya un instant
avec le détecteur de mensonges vas-y
repose là moi
serai-je
qu'est-ce que tu kiffes le plus entre
guillemets et vous annonçait ce que tu
me kiffe plus que kim sang fait répond
par oui ou non
rien d'autre je suis au nom pas de mon
frère pas de ta vie à aa
je souris ou encore confiant sera n'y a
pas de écoutez je vais t'expliquer
attendais pas du tout ce que tu crois
oui oh la la
tuvalu orale
à
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais te dire la vérité je te
jure que je la machine dit n'importe
quoi
je te le jure
j'étais posé la question parce que
j'avais confiance en mes jeux tous dit
que j'avais confiance en toi raid jack
lui donne en spectacle avait confiance
on craint si je retourne demain soir
c'est juste parce que je dois sortir un
album
[Applaudissements]
machine de merde pas jo alors je vais te
dire c'est difficile de choisir entre
ton papa et à maman a enfin mal comme
non mais oui j'aime j'aime les deux mais
la machine a menti ça veut dire que vous
préférez date joachim s'y met alors au
game alors alors j'aime les deux mois
c'est le mois moi j'aime la france
voilà j'aime non mais tu veux pas plutôt
faire gims pour lui raconter cette
histoire on va faire un petit 10 ans il
s'est tu sais très bien qu'il préfère
on va pas revenir là dessus qu'on passe
à autre chose